hi I'm Dennis Rodman I'm the only guy on
this stage has done a really cool
hey Ed Norton what's up man everyone
goes by Edward and not in because he is
a real dick Ed Norton was in three of my
favorite things American History X Fight
Club and Selma Hayek Martha Stewart I
see you right there baby
the next time you go to jail please call
me I will secure your release and look
at that guy with a little rail looking
like Damon artis bobblehead so
what I see you over there baby I see you
silly Shepard it sounds like a disease
that you get when you're a sheep
[Applause]
Jeff was Jeff's dick is so small it
looks like a hat for his nuts he's been
calling that Joseph a all night if
one more person calls Joseph a puss
again I'm going to lick him for 20
minutes
[Applause]
Bruce Willis the last time I saw you was
in the strip club
do you remember that I do yes yes you do
and Nicki you was great on the stage
baby
Bruce you keep making these
bombs my guess what
so does Kim Jong Un's but at least Kim
is smart enough not to release his
you